that's her been dropped to a bombshell
last night let's make that two
bombshells actually because he told two
women that he loves them now that is a
cardinal sin on the show The Bachelor is
all supposed to say the l word until he
puts a ring on it
so our lauren zima press been to find
out what was he thinking when this was
going on I love two women but now I'm
happily in love with one and that's
gonna stay that way for the rest of my
life it'll be another two weeks before
we get to the finale and find out who
really won Ben's heart but last night's
episode was just plain awkward I am
completely in love with you
I've known I'm in love with you for a
while as well what Ben took all three
ladies Jojo Lauren and Kayla to the
fantasy suite but in the end it was
Kayla who went home I didn't see this
coming I wake still love him I didn't
feel like I wanted to question the
fantasies we night because I felt like
that time we had did progress our
relationship and you know he's I'm not
done that there are other women there
and so he still has you know to make to
say goodbye to people and you have any
regrets from that experience I guess I
do have one regret and like it's not
it's that I didn't you know get things
off my chest as soon as I felt them
because I felt because I kind of held
things in which made me sound confusing
like I sound right now and um you know
Bendis doesn't waste any time and I feel
like I should should've done that as
well and though then officially
announced his engagement to the love of
his life today we'll have to watch all
the messy details unfold before any
bachelor wedding come around I will get
married tomorrow if that was the right
and wise decision for us to make as a
couple I don't think it is
I like I said I want to show her off I
want to date her well when a love on
love on her in public I don't wanna push
off a wedding I don't think she does
my life is committed to one person and
I'm excited about that commitment but am
I gonna get married tomorrow let's you
know soon
you